are you interested at all in this oj
documentary reg mmm not really
obviously we know most of the
particulars I am just so curious all
this is just now coming out what is this
20 21 years later that yeah you know
we're hearing you know reaching out to
Bob Costas you know during the NBA
Finals versus New York in Houston and
you know not taking his arthritis
medicine you know so his hands would
continue to swell how is that just now
coming up 20 years later
did you know oj know i may have met him
but did not know did not know yeah i'm i
met him a couple of times when he was
working as a broadcaster and then i
interviewed him after he got out of
prison and that was not how did that go
because i'm sure your producers probably
peppered you with questions they wanted
to know did you have questions going
into that interview that look this is
going to be my outline these are the
ones i want him to answer it was people
long well trying to persuade you to kind
of you know put him on the spot no it
was gonna be football related questions
that was it
because i you know he'd already been
found not guilty and i think this may be
2004 and i go to miami and i said look
it's just gonna be football related and
so we go in and we're just talking about
college we talked about pros and the
awkward part was those tapes are 30
minutes long my cameraman as we get to
the very end of the tape then he says uh
gonna stop you here we're gonna change
tapes so it's just me and OJ and we're
about three feet apart i my body
language during the interview was
terrible reg i'm leaning back as far as
I can in my chair I don't even realize
it as if AJ has a knife on me
okay so I I sit there
silence as we're waiting for my
cameraman to put in another tape and OJ
says to me do you think I did it oh okay
now that's a little creepy you know what
I said I said did what oh I swear to God
I did and he said no he said killed
those people and I said yes you did yeah
yes and that was the end of it my
cameraman said I got the new tape in
fresh tape in we can we can start
rolling again so I then proceeded to ask
him questions about football and he's
just looking at you like this do you
think he was guilty well yes in his mind
he thought he was innocent oh I know
right he did convince himself that he
wasn't guilty but so this is January of
o3 Paulie yep
oh man so we get done he proceeds to
start telling me how crazy his life is
and that he said for instance I'm
walking by a hotel room in Vegas and
they're shooting a porno and they say -
they they say to me as I'm walking by
juice we'll give you three million
dollars to come in and be in the porno
movie he goes that's how crazy my life
is and I'm thinking do you think your
life is crazy with that yeah not one of
my best moments when I thought hey let's
talk to OJ about football because he
wanted to convince me that he was not
guilty and I wasn't buying any of it
well kudos for you for being honest and
saying do what and yeah I just I wish it
would have been on camera because that I
mean it was it was really impactful
powerful and I thought okay why not just
tell him that I I think you did it if he
wants to talk because I had said look
there won't be any questions about it
but he threw out wanted to keep
convincing me that he didn't do it and
once tape started reroll eeen and after
he
ask you that question in my opinion as a
journalist I think it's fair game you
should have brought it up then because
he asked the question yes he did do you
think I did it
but I had promised him it wasn't about
that so I was trying to hold up my end
of the bargain and I didn't want to make
him mad
you cameraman had your back no all right
let me get two last night by the way
Reggie Miller joining us here right so
what did you expect last night going
into the game I expected what we saw
unbelievable performance by LeBron James
I wish I would have said this yesterday
I expected him to go I don't think this
happened but I expected him to go to the
free-throw line twelve plus times but if
flub Ron James is making that mid-range
shot we saw a lot last night and those
timely threes there's nothing you're
gonna be able to do against him and with
Kyrie being on fire as well if those two
guys continue to play like that the next
two games our next game for in the case
of the cats because it's a single
elimination for them there's nothing
that the Warriors will be able to do
really there's not if they continue to
make plays now I'm not saying they've
both got to score 40 but if they
continue to attack and make plays
there's nothing the Warriors are gonna
be able to do and my question is where
has this been especially for LeBron
where it's been through the first four
games
well kairi's played well the last three
games but as I was saying I really in
LeBron case yes Kyrie played great yeah
they've had no answer for Kyrie but
LeBron and the attacking and you know
being aggressive and looking for a shot
through four quarters not three not two
yeah I was saying that to the dance that
the game plan has got to be don't worry
about anybody else hits you and Kyrie
and you have to make have to make a
commitment and put pressure on Golden
State I want Golden State to be on their
heels as opposed to the other way around
which is what Golden State does to you
so Kyrie has to say to Steph Curry I'm
gonna keep you honest this entire game
and LeBron has got to say to Iguodala
or whoever's gardening him I'm taking it
and I'm taking it hard as many times as
I can here and you got a he has to go to
the line at least 10 to 15 times so I I
can't sit there and worry about Kevin
love's feelings or jr. Smith or anybody
else who's going to be involved here
those two guys have got to combine to
take 50 shots in Game six agree and in
game six on Thursday I look for a better
performance from Kevin Love because
before this series began I told you that
the Warriors and we're going to take
Kevin Love out of this series you know
that's exactly what they've done but if
they want to reverse history because no
team has ever come back in the NBA
Finals down 3-1 they are going to need a
performance or performances from Kevin
Love it's been a great two men show
especially last night in game five
between Kyrie and LeBron but that won't
get it done again if there's a game
seven back in Oracle because they're
gonna need a whole cast of characters to
win that so you know those guys will
play well at in Game six you know I
thought Smith played well through the
first half he made shot he made plays
but again Kyrie has been spectacular in
this series yeah you're right about
putting pressure on love but more
importantly his primary guy that's
guarding him has been klay Thompson yeah
but you got I got I got to wear him out
I got it I can't let him get in a kind
of rhythm on offense I got to have him
feeling bad that he can't stop me on
defense but again I like what Steve Kerr
said after the game I like the position
where versus what their which is true
yes yes and this is very unlike the OKC
being up 3-1 versus the Warriors you
know we said well Golden State have to
do is win one game on the road and
everything shift and they did that in
Game six and they had the game seven at
home well what you're telling the
Cleveland Cavaliers to do is they have
to win two games in Oracle they won last
night and now they're gonna have to win
again if again if they win Game six they
have to come back and win game
seven on Sunday also draymond Green
coming back if you're the Cavaliers how
much are you trying to bait him knowing
that if he picks up another flagrant
then he doesn't play in Game seven Wow
hopefully he's smarter I mean he knew he
knew the rules
he knew the limit the number he was at
going into Game five he understood that
so it happened you move on you know it's
time for us to move on the game happened
everyone I don't think he should have
been suspended but you move on from it
he heard his team not being out there
but let me just say this too it's not
like draymond has been destroying teams
and playing great throughout these
playoffs he was terrible in the OKC
series now do I like my chances and does
he do so much for your ballclub
absolutely yes do I love my chances with
him on the floor absolutely but it's not
like he's been you know destroying teams
he was terrible at OKC series yeah I
wonder what I know I wonder how he'll
play though I wonder what his mindset is
too sometimes you want to overcompensate
the fact that you weren't there for your
team last night
now you're going to Game six but you
know I'm not worried about dream on if
the Warriors want to win back-to-back
championships Steph Curry is gonna have
to play like he did in Game four I up
until Game four Steph has really been a
non-factor in this series now you said
no he had 20-plus points last night but
where those points really impactful
clays points were impactful worse des
points impactful in their game know the
story of the game with Kyrie and LeBron
and clay and you still maintain that
kind that Steph Curry's banged up
although he said look you know whoever
said I got problems with my shoulders or
I'm gonna need surgery
that's crazy you still maintain there's
something to Steph Curry I do I do and
when that came out that he potentially
could have surgery
me and the shoulder it doesn't surprise
me now again he is supposed to come back
and counteract and say nope nothing's
wrong with me because if you can lace
them up and you're out there then we're
assuming you're a hundred percent but I
would not be surprised if he has some
type of surgery or he takes the whole
summer off because he just does not look
physically well he does not look like
the guy we saw during the regular season
after the ankle injury early in that
Houston series and then the knee injury
well there's something wrong with him
clearly because if you look at those new
shoes that he's wearing anything stalled
would you yeah I would I would rock
those Steph I would rock those those dad
shoes come on
no no I've seen what you wear what you
always sorta thing do you think he
signed off on him he had to they're
they're his he's he's under armours
basketball unit yes and they also have
nursing shoes apparently oh that's not
right the adore not wear those shoes red
I might rock him no Ike I've seen would
you wear you would not wear those in the
booth they would go what happened reg
are you oh man Reggie my right yeah I
might get ran out of it like look out
what
Reggie's old he's got those orthotics or
something what you know what as much as
people are killing those shoes and
saying how old-school they are they're
gonna become fashionable because
everyone's killing those shoes what
that's how it works
those shoes could cost him the series
don't say that he's not wearing him
right he just wears no yeah those are
just like kick around soon oh I don't
want to be like the Air Force Ones right
you never had your own shoe right no oh
you said I wasn't that good of a player
come on Antoine Walker had his own shoes
reg I wasn't that high on the Nike food
chain you think if you had gone to like
Fela my grand Hill maybe you got your
own LA gear I did no actually I did have
my own shoe when I
first started I was with do you remember
spot dilt yes shoes yeah okay yes I did
have had the Reggie Miller spot go
did you help design him no but it was
the ones you that was had them for one
year I think they went under so bad
you're thinking hey look at what Jordan
did for Nike I'm doing that for spot
bill ground ground Miller there was Air
Jordan there was our own Miller oh my
god I love you know what people always
have those on YouTube or Craigslist can
someone please buy those spot bills eBay
please find those spots yes falling we
have some pictures of spot belt shoes
from the early 80s there they're clunky
they're little clunky they are they are
but I warm with clouds
thank you vaudeville for me being your
signature athlete do you still get Nike
stuff like you know oh yes I do
if I oh yeah like for basketball camps
and things like that
oh yeah yeah cuz but they don't send
things just to be Cindy I told you I'm
very very low on the Nike totem pole but
you're holding and Phil and I we went
into hall of fame together Phil Knight
but do you like it was Oregon UCLA that
there's an issue there with Phil Knight
no I think it was Michael Jordan racing
wait do you think Jordan said to Phil
Knight egg you know you know no let me
stop all that okay what Paulie and the I
team is gonna bring it all back together
guess who else with a spot built guy in
the 70s early 80s oh my god who Oh Jay
Simpson athletes were spot built the
juice mobiles Wow the spot build juice
mobiles then I like it
spot bill Paulie are there pictures of
me wearing those fossils because they
were high we're looking we're looking
we're high look there's a picture of
everything someone has pictures of me
wearing those spots let's see if we can
find those by the way
who wins Game six Cleveland
all along I said this game series is
going seven all right this is going
seven okay and then who wins in Game
seven
oh the state yeah you already have a
Golden State winning in seven yeah hey
by the way I stole your dinner you do
and I'll collect when you're out here
for sports Jeff well I'm out in July if
you're around so just beautiful yeah so
if you want to I mean it could be where
you go to dinner with somebody you want
to go with and then all pay for it I
don't have to go to dinner I want to go
to dinner with Theodora Reggie I always
look for to our dinners then we have
something huge like we've got a picture
here of Reggie dunking wearing a pair of
like white and blue spot bill sneakers
it's him an x-man who's wearing the same
pair but green and the biggest news is
that he's dunking Wow
thank you for all you people who said it
happened one I like that picture Seaton
Paulie please wait is he dunking over
x-men nah now they're both it's separate
pictures he's part of the poster so it's
a would it's a wide open dunk by reg
like he's not posterizing anybody know
now there's a new Sean Bradley reg come
on everybody dunked over Sean Bradley
look my first two years I could jump
that was it my first two years and then
what happened I just you know things
happen and then they happen and now you
need Steph Curry shoes to walk around
the neighborhood there that's right in a
walker - I'm bringing spot okay
those were hot x-men and the Jews were
rocking up yeah now someone go say
something no
the last man no not gonna saw on looking
at these shoes you're with dr. Jack
Ramsay that's right my first coat look
at that you're looking clean with those
red thank you thank you they were hot
yeah yeah yeah did you rock them could
you write to rob those were people these
were the eighties I could rock those
before I could the Steph Curry nursing
okay 1987 they were hot enjoy the game
reg always made a proof tank
all right thanks bud you're the best
behind that's a Reggie Aloysius Miller
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience